c'est toujours bon album avec la ville
toujours bonne mais c'est vrai que la
dénomination réseau et qui réalise la
parade mais gbagbo toujours et toujours
là dans le sens où l'organisation en
elle-même
concernant l'animation reste à leur
charge la charge elle-même et puis au
niveau sécurité mais la ville fait un
gros travail sans leur monnaie et c'est
ce qui permet de perdurer une trêve de
façon à ce que ça tourne que chaque
année sont pas les mêmes groupes qui
vont et viennent mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya une base parce que pour arriver à la
liste de dix neuvième édition
nous tenons compte aussi de ceux qui ont
aidé à pouvoir réaliser une telle
manifestation et qui a plus de l'ampleur
et qui dépasse largement le cadre de la
marche normalement devant le sénat au
stade de pointe à pitre guadeloupe
et puis les groupes
demandes uniques tels que les groupes du
corps du collectif de rouge donc on peut
nommer comme ça à la volée le ballon
le passage carbone plastique justement
sans boulot qu'on a des groupes de la
zone nord ce qu'il faut pas les oublier
les colibris du bon élève et en
différents arias authentique
j'ai aucune base du robert donc on a
tout plein de boue est également un bouc
qui lui tient à coeur parce qu'on
intègre parmi
la pléiade de location de grues magic
hour du lamentin un groupe de jeunes à
qui nous
nous offrons la possibilité de se
produire sur une parade qui est apprécié
par tout le monde et surtout pour les
personnes ou de mort